UFOs strange objects in the sky alien
bodies alien species have you seen the
spacecraft I could answer that question
behind behind close stores there are so
many unexplained things in this universe
and from time to time these objects
events or phenomena are captured on
video today we have some incredible UFO
Clips it became clear to me that this is
visual effects do you have damning
evidence as well I have damning
testimony what we have incredible
crypted paranormal Clips my instincts
tell me that this is not visual effects
so you guys say it's real I want to
believe but exceptional claims require
exceptional evidence as visual effects
artists we can look at these and try to
determine if there's any visual effects
happening and if so what gives it away I
kind of feel like I'm in a movie theater
and I'm like EES dropping on you
guys oh yeah you guys like aliens huh I
got something for
you we all love Americana we all love
trains don't we well it turns out that
uh today we're finding ourselves in the
intersection of Americana freight trains
and the Paranormal finally oh my gosh
finally they've oh my gosh I can't wait
the date is October 10th location
Silverton Colorado a little train going
through the Durango Silverton Narrow
Gauge Railroad let's just take a look at
something they caught on their
sighting wait we're starting with
Bigfoot clip oh man I haven't seen good
Bigfoot footage in so long my instincts
tell me that this is not visual effects
yeah this looks like 100% real footage
to me yes it does right out the gate all
like the little micro Jitters are picked
up so you guys say it's real this is
real footage this is real footage this
is real footage I V real footage now do
you think this is real
Bigfoot I don't profess to know how big
the feet are from this distance it could
just be a guy in a suit so easily it's
got human proportions basically one
thing in particular though is on the leg
you can see like a crease of claw dude I
was going to say yes on the legs cuz
it's such hard shadowing you can see a
little bit of draping cloth over
something thinner there so that's why I
wanted to pull up actual costume
pictures here cuz you can see how a lot
of them have like loose fitting legs
here so that looks pretty fake right
it's like okay this isn't real but I
wanted to go a little bit deeper here I
actually was able to locate this
original Facebook post I think it has
all the evidence we need to discern
whether this is real or fake we know
where this is filmed Silverton Colorado
on the Durango Silverton Narrow Gauge
Railroad they said they filmed this
after leaving Silverton and returning to
Durango we would see that it would have
to be on the left side of the train we
got a lot of Rocky outcroppings here
plus also there's a lot of Road access
to this area this is like still right
next to the town where there's humans so
I want one stage further according to
the Durango Herald multiple tricksters
have dawned sasquat suits and run
alongside the Narrow Gauge Railroad to
entertain tourists they said that the
sheriff the county sheriff used to do it
before taking his post wow maybe their
Sheriff isn't
Bigfoot we don't know man I kind of feel
like it's a guy in a suit for bigfoot is
the lowest bar across like if it could
be a guy in a suit you already loseing
that one this is stilt
on Malaysian Airlines flight through 70
disappeared in 2014 shortly after two
videos hit the internet recently these
video clips have been making a
Resurgence people talking about them
again people claiming they have
undeniable proof that they're real let's
start by watching
Eclipse okay that's a white
[Applause]
thing the whole frame gets
brighter so one of our base requirements
is multiple Witnesses multiple camera
angles this one comes with a second
[Music]
clip just like who's why what is this
plane doing are there they're taking
like evasive maneuvers who's filming
this like what's going on like it's also
why is it so shaky cuz it's like should
be on a nice smooth
[Laughter]
gimbal so there you have it it's a weird
one it is a weird one wouldn't that be
cool if that was real well actually no
that'd be terrible because you know yeah
there's a lot of people on that plane
although I guess they're not dying
they're going to a new dimension yeah
they might be living it up the YouTube
channel since this was uploaded does not
exist no original footage just YouTube
videos it's not it's not good when your
original footage is a YouTube video yeah
that's a that's a step guys is is this
real or is this VFX I'm getting VFX e
Vibes right now the first angle is
something you could do very simply the
second one is way weirder so people have
said that because these came out so
quickly after the airline disappeared
it'd be impossible to do these visual
effects how how fast could you guys do
these shots uh real fast yeah as little
as an
hour
as long you know as long as four to five
you know you could you could do this in
four to 5 hours okay okay after
analyzing this footage it became clear
to me that this is visual effects I
thing that stands out most to me is we
go back to that first clip so look at
the background are we a satellite assume
we're a satellite do you notice anything
weird about the background oh that the
clouds are not evolving in any way shape
or form nothing's evolving it's a still
frame it's a still frame Thank You Ren
hey guys how fast do satellites go
17,000 mph yeah would you jump to
footage of the internet space
station oh
damn look the fact of the matter is that
satellite footage the satellite needs to
be moving it can't be static there would
be Parallax between the clouds and the
ground that's a big one but you know
what that doesn't rule out that thermal
shot right what's up with that thermal
shot thermal cameras like they don't
have they don't have grain it's not
underexposed footage if there's any sort
of noise pattern notice it's a fixed
noise pattern it's the idea of like your
image is under almost like a dirty lens
how do you make it look like it's
thermal well there's a filter in After
Effects called colorama what colorama
does is it goes all right let's take
black to white and instead of do black
to white we're going to fill it in with
different colors along the way a rainbow
a spectrum and then you know that looks
like thermal footage it's just not
accurate however in this case we see the
engines are hot so maybe you go in touch
up the engines give them a little track
some like heat points on there one weird
thing I'm noticing with The Thermals is
on that shock wave in the second clip
like how cold is that Shock Wave Wait
like is that like a is that like a zero
and so I'm confused why it's so dark
when like we clearly see the engines are
like hot points we're getting the
yellows the Reds because if it's a super
dark hole why is it so bright there and
then in the other one it's like a pitch
black abyss the crazy thing about
thermals is they see through mist and
smoke and all that kind of stuff if we
look at this clip from veritasium we
can't see him cuz photons can't pierce
the fog but that that deep infrared that
long wavelength infrared goes right
through it the fog is invisible to
infrared so those plain contrails
shouldn't even be showing up on thermal
the underlying footage is CGI it's a 3D
render on top of a Ste frame of clouds
on top of a still frame of clouds and
the reason it is is the particle effect
the trail from the plane those are
Sprites overlaid on top of each other
giving us this additive stacked opacity
which creates that buildup in the
Highlight that we see there if we were
to do a volumetric smoke simulation of a
similar Trail like that you would see
that it doesn't overlap and it has more
consistent values across the whole Arc
not just where it's you know uding
itself it's a CGI render setting this up
in 3D is almost trivially simple you lay
a path you set an object to follow the
path you get a little triple helix for
the other objects to come in put a
particle emitter for the contrails I'd
be curious to see when this came out
versus when the Sprite Trail tutorial on
video co-pilot came out I think it was
roughly around this
time but the biggest nail in the coffin
which if I would have led with this
would have made this whole discussion
move it's not really fun do you have
damning evidence as well I have damning
testimony what if you tell me that this
is the shock
wave do we have the shock wave on our
server we do now actually wait
what I found the stock fo the
J yeah we didn't some people unreddit
did this is a stock footage clip from
the 9s oh hell yeah there's the clip
from the video and here is the stock
footage it's perfect oh it's perfect
Cinderella baby Cinderella Man that's it
H slipped right
on Wow an Isa dude an identified stock
asset some people have said you know
pixels don't match perfectly and you
know what of course they don't match
perfectly I don't have the exact
settings that the artists used but if
you look at it it's the exact same I
can't yeah like I literally can't wear
these glasses anymore like there's like
nothing it's just so debugged this is
visual effects it's really well done
visual effects so I had the joy of being
a guest on a podcast the Danny Jones
podcast they had a UFO believer who
believes that this footage is real come
on the podcast and they asked me to
break down if it was visual effects or
not and I presented this Danny sent me
the reaction of the UFO olist so as a
statement of fact those do not match
dude it
is exact this is like saying that my
butthole is your butthole because
they're similar right it's not we don't
have the same butthole because of that
so if you want to see our in-depth full
respones to this UFO believer well we
have that on our website cord
digital.com we're not trying to get into
a super deep back forth back and forth
here on on the YouTube channel but yeah
it's over there if you want to go check
it out and of course you can watch the
actual moment over on Danny Jones's
podcast there's a link in the
description below go check it out well
guys I've heard your complaints I know
you're you're tired of looking at little
orbs in the sky and that's why I'm
bringing the real deal today I'm
bringing undeniable proof of aliens not
in their ships but on Earth here with us
there's something that has been highly
requested for this show and it's time to
give the people what they want I'd like
to introduce you to skinny Bob oh oh
skinny skinny Bob
this YouTube channel ivan0135
uploaded four secret government tapes oo
and has since disappeared entirely
skinny Bob is not a foreign word to me
in fact I have seen many skinny Bob
request emails Grace my inbox this is
the most requested clip we've ever had
he's the OG alien look at this look at
this o this is from a secret council
meeting I think cameras don't go out of
focus like that this not when I film I
film like this like in out in out in and
like this is someone who is not secretly
recording this is KGB footage right who
is
going and then cutting the camera
Stalin's top
men oh yeah hell
FLH look this is this is some pretty
well done CG but the motion immediately
immediately makes me think CGI because
the weight doesn't shift correctly when
he moves around like he's moving the
head he's moving his body there's no
counter motion right also if the head is
that big like what is it filled with is
it fluid brain matter or is it just air
cuz if it's air I could imagine it
moving like that but if it's anything
denser than that like it's going to
require some you know counterbalance on
your torso to carry a noggin of that
size and the cloth too you know right
the cloth is just a static wrinkle this
was uploaded in 2011 and an argument
that I've seen a lot is that this kind
of CGI wasn't possible in
2011 now just a quick reminder Avatar
came out in
2010 uh Jurassic Park came out in what
was it
92 but this one blinks blinks didn't
weren't even a thing until
2013 and there's also one other thing in
particular on screen here I want to know
if you guys notice it that is that I
don't I can't really make sense of
what's the time code for yeah yeah
digital time code is this 8mm
film
you Pi up a good point what is this bull
crap is there a higher quality version
this is like a postage stamp this is
like a gift that someone ran through
media encoder and then uploaded why are
we watching this guys there's nothing to
analyze here Sam's not convinced I can
tell but here's the thing about this
community yes there are some people who
will believe at the drop of a hat but
that's not the majority a lot of people
will dig very very deep these series of
videos going as viral as they have has
elicited a response from the community
that will blow your mind there is a
skinny Bob website that does literally
the deepest dive into any UFO footage
I've ever seen in my life this is really
well done dude wow this is insane I
don't know that this is warranted for
the for what we saw personally there
there's also some other things that are
concerning oh there's a Smoking Gun this
one Smoking Gun is testimony I want to I
want to see a smokey ass gun smokiest
gun someone Tracked
Down the exact film grade they did it
you want to talk exact match those you
want to talk one those Heroes incredible
I am so impressed isn't that amazing
they track down the actual
elements
God
damn oh my we got them look how they put
TV static over
film this is a great breakdown of what
it goes into actually having composite
degraded footage with as smokey as this
gun is there is still conversation being
had they say but what about what's
underneath all of this the source
footage it's like it's like I'm outside
I'm like oh my God I found a video of a
real alien and I'm like should I upload
it it's like no wait pon.com
[Laughter]
perfect wow I can't believe skinny Bob
just got dunked on the this hard that
it's just like it's it's I just want
shout out to the SKB Community love you
guys thank you for suggesting that we
look at the clips and most most
importantly thank you to the people who
have dissected it and broken it down
frankly you guys have done way more
debunking than we've ever done Bravo
this is It's devastating cuz again this
was highly requested maybe we haven't
captured a live alien live aliens are
sneaky they get away all the time you
know what's not good at running away
dead aliens oh they're bad at it man
they're bad at moving in general this is
as good as evidence gets to me these
small mummified specimens were unveiled
at Mexico's first ever UFO hearing
yesterday these guys do you know these
guys we are dealing with a nonhuman
specimens look at that cute little
bed why are they all dusty they are in a
nice bed why did they pour dust into the
bed after they put the alien in
it dude they're both about a thousand
years old are they plaster molds of mil
I'm I'm so impressed of how serious this
is being taken like look at this yeah
this this was legit this was taken very
very seriously and these were brought
forward by Jose haime me who ironically
has been on this show before Oh really
it's not his first rodeo wait is he one
of the guys who filmed all like the
little ones flying in the air the
multiple angle cluster shot and he
delivered this is his latest creation
well I mean you say that but here's the
reality he brought this before the
government and he actually gave the
bodies over to a University San Louis
Gonzaga University in Peru and they
worked on it for I think about 4 years
they were investigating these things and
they deemed them to be authentic what
that clip they deemed these bodies to be
authentic a university oh they x-rayed
them look at that they x-rayed them
freaking MRI dude look how Cas he just
carrying this mummy around I don't like
how he's handling it I feel like you
shouldn't handle it like that can you
imagine toot and Common's freaking tomb
opens and they just like lift it
up look at look look real mummy real
look real
alien is this like a real University the
interesting thing about universities in
Peru is there is an overseen board and
they essentially reward accreditation to
universities that meet the minimum
requirement to be a university and the
San Louis Gonzaga University has
accreditation so they are a legitimate
University and they meet the standard
for Education there is one caveat they
did lose it in
2019 which is when they got the mummies
oh no um and it's worth noting that with
this decision they became the first
Public University that does not
satisfactorily pass the evaluation which
is unfortunate for the sake of our
argument here signs are not strong and
also haime unfortunately in 2017 2 years
prior to this uh he was caught uh with
similar mummies that were proven to be
made of uh I believe papier-mâché and
glue which is also not a good look
considering two years later he comes
back with very similar ones but here's
the thing just because you faked winning
the lottery Nico doesn't mean you can't
win it the next week okay you know what
you know what those are some wise ass
words by my friend the boy who cried
wolf comes to mind and we know the moral
of that story right guys it's that in
the end right after lie after lie after
lie the wolf was real no never believe
the
wol maybe this isn't what we're looking
for just yet I don't know I I you know I
don't think any of these have convinced
any of us unfortunately it's not to say
the truth isn't still out there not to
say there's not footage that will still
blow our minds I think the only thing
I'm convinced of is that we all hold in
our hearts a desire to believe we all
want to see Wonder in the Stars that's
what I'm really understanding here is
gosh it' be so cool wouldn't it that
would be amazing that'd be that's Wonder
that's excitement that's Adventure right
thank you to everyone who sent us Clips
please continue to send us anything that
strikes fancy to debunk cord or
[Music]
digital.com